hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
skinwalker okay I just got back from the
very long day at a YouTube space which
is actually this really cool place other
YouTube built for YouTube partners to go
and use whatever tools they have
available camera equipment studio rooms
green screens recording equipment
post-production equipment computers
recording booths everything that's just
available in there for us to use and I
was so honored to be there I got to meet
a ton of other channels and I'm gonna be
working on a few videos with them as
well as with maker studios to make just
an absolute ton of content but as far as
my channel go I feel really bad because
I've been very very lacking on these
videos the reason why I didn't have any
in it before I went out is because I had
been doing three videos a day on both
outlast and on an Asian machine for pigs
those two games just hit hard and fast
and I wanted to make sure that I got all
of those games done while I was home so
that I could do it in the comfort of my
home and not have to worry about trying
to record it on the road like I am now
but anyway I just got back to where we
were before we're just walking to the
cabin now and I'm going to help Celeste
up because I was terribly stupid before
okay anyway so I'm just skipping ahead
of the dialog because we've already read
all of this I nearly tripped over
Celeste what she fell helped to last up
okay let's do it
I took Celeste hand you dragged her to
her feet it was giving even Mystere if
now for the plat flight they wouldn't
have any idea who she was
wait a minute I recognize yet we were
getting to the cabin wait a minute what
but wait a minute did I actually say
okay never mind again I had that feeling
that something was watching me my gut
was screaming at me that something
somewhere was wrong
I realize a sound from earlier was back
softer but still present I've already
read all this see me Celeste still
holding my hand okay is that Celeste I
better be collect Darren and lead
Michael to the left who in the heck was
the guy besides Michael my grip on
Celeste hand tightened and I quickened
my pace okay
maybe oh oh no way that was a thing I
did before okay never mind then the
cabin appeared out of nowhere okay this
is where we're starting to go okay it
was easier to make out everyone who
everyone was I looked at the vignette so
Michael does I get it so I am holding
the hand of the thing the thing whose
head I was holding lean in front of Mike
it wasn't the last handed that that head
is freaky I should have ran or screamed
but my body was clenching up for no
reason the thing turned and walked into
the midst wait a minute but how rim Andy
I caught up with the others as I entered
the cabin practically in tears they
couldn't find the car and we're arguing
about where they put it
wait a minute yeah this is all the same
wait a minute what's happening he
falleth there I don't get it it's the
same what the hell hell if I know
ask him oh wait no I'm okay alright it's
different now goody goody gumdrops hey
don't touch the door wasn't gonna I'm
gonna get the shotgun
I don't know there's a shotgun in there
I am almost positive about that okay
whatever
hey hey yo hey out there what are you
what are you doing there she's breathing
quite heavily oh it's a sturdy door
it'll be all right won't it
we're safe here it's cool man well
alright then did he go away I don't know
maybe I should go out and check all by
myself let me start a fire
I don't have any matches the ambiance is
quite ooh but he can't get in right yeah
hey Celeste baby wait no Celeste he is
just trying to scare us take it easy
uh maybe we shouldn't hey buddy I'm
starting to believe what you say you saw
earlier oh really what clued you in see
he's just trying to scare us hey don't
touch the door okay so I got to go find
Celeste wherever she is can I look out
the window or something a couple of
books and board games hey creepy woods
key hello whoa this cabin is big Celeste
how you doing are you really Celeste she
seems to be hyperventilating the door is
locked and it's the only way in we're
safe here so let's just you and me kiddo
Ned no no response is that really
Celeste that better actually be Celeste
this time or else I'm going to flip a
hint okay more creepy woods I'm guessing
that when I look out I knew it I knew it
who is that he's got a red face okay
alrighty then I need to find some
matches to light the fire because he hit
the power and I need to oh hey wait how
did you get back here hey wait a minute
what well no no how'd you get back here
that's not right something's not right
there again I am trying to be a bit
quieter because I do have neighbors and
I don't want to bother them with is that
good I better be Michael hey Michael you
dick turn around
oh you saw something looking like me
oh wait a minute better not touch it why
I just spit on my monitor ill uh I'm
gonna look out the other window hang on
maybe he's there suddenly a strong sense
of nausea hit me there was something in
the air I could feel the horror overtake
you okay who's gonna aah
what what's going on my picking up some
radio frequencies here oh my hey wait a
minute
III don't feel so good
is someone knocking on the door better
not touch it um what the hell is
happening here I'm gonna look out the
window but it's all gonna be psycho
crazy bonkers I do not like being in an
unfamiliar place when I'm playing these
games
okay nothing out there let me go check
on the other guys because apparently
pull okay Celeste you were freaking me
out there I was about to say
ooh okay it's less not doing too good
don't know what he's doing what are you
doing down there
I can't get up maybe try using your legs
what is going on here something very
strange and very disorienting is
happening just a sounds it's a cacophony
of nightmares they are very simple
kitchen who's your nun what to do what
to do what am i doing I had to lie down
I'm just gonna take some less bed hope
she comes back later for a little I
waiting for the world to stop spinning I
looked out a window oh oh oh there was
someone in the tree I stared back top be
able to register what's going on I
quickly pulled the blinds down I didn't
know a cabin came with blondes Celeste
came through the door she looked pale
and a shovel I shall delet I dragged her
to bowl oh really now she was gasping
for zeref something was suffocating her
eventually your breathing became more
regular I asked her where the others
were she shrugged ah okay so hmm
I thought that I was it was still is but
what we what are you doing no God not
this one I'm the real one the one out
there that's the imposter uh-uh
maybe I would have stabbed her if the
voice at the door hadn't changed into
some low deep guttural voice then it
became hi who I was going on
I'm so confused okay there's why oh I
was at the front door I didn't even know
there was nothing but a trail of black
liquid ah how about we do not go outside
what Moody might not be the best idea to
go out sir let's not if the feeling in
my gut is telling me not to unless
elastically oh I don't know I don't know
what the right choice is anymore saloons
baby suddenly are the sinking feeling in
my stomach like something was seriously
out of place we will soon find out oh my
god it that shot to death I know he may
be a gaping bullet wound in his chest
would be some clue that he was shot to
death Celeste isn't here recently shot
to death wounds rubbish out okay so you
can see the shotgun wounds in him but
not her oh my god they're all dead
uh I'm guessing it's time to go outside
now
waitwhat Celeste wait and let me go back
was Celeste actually in that room I
didn't see anyone in the room but it
could have just been who shot them or
Janna did I shoot them Oh suddenly I
realized was there really someone
outside no what the hell the shotgun how
tempting it had been I had been looking
for the ripe of what what to kill my
friends what you just had to do it why
I'm trying not to yell at you you
bastard always taking me for granted
those bastards just because I'm nothing
special get your teeth up not to mess
with Jo call me every stupid reason what
is that fate oh come on you [ __ ] God
you don't do that I can't save can't
save oh my god you tion of a [ __ ] okay
I actually have the time so I'm gonna
get through to the other thing I'll be
back in a bit what the hell how am I
supposed to know how am I supposed to
know sorry neighbours alright we are
back in the game sorry for the delay I'm
actually gonna try to make right choices
but they seem to be completely freaking
random at this point so let's see what
we have here oh it may not be the best
idea well how about we do it anyway
we're going outside
the thing was nowhere to be seen
just as I was turning around I took a
look at the roof there it
was there what was it was close to a
corner about to turn what an albino male
with a really long limbs stander man he
was facing away from me suddenly the
heads wiggled 180 degrees and stared at
me I started choking up as if suffocated
it was hard to breath the thing opened
its mouth slowly and deliberately I
thought it was going to be army when its
tongues snake staked out on the tip of
the tongue was my face like a tumor
watch what's ice close lift up turn like
some psycho smile there's a legend
somewhere that when you see a
doppelganger you die I thought of that
legend but then the creature rounded the
corner and it was gone I lost it and
followed vision hazy maharba suddenly
seemed the ears splitting to me I was
stumbling because my legs seemed unable
to coordinate suddenly I stumbled
forward and toppled down once I lay
there face down in the grass my body
seemed to shut down I couldn't move I
couldn't even turn my head there was
something dripping on my back my eyelids
seemed heavy and study closing of their
own Accords I saw white feet with long
fingers four toes step into view when my
eyes opened Celeste was shaking me she
was on the brink of tears and her voice
was cracking get up get up that bastard
was in your skin what my head hurt I was
about to ask her what happened when she
started pulling me backwards towards the
door we toppled out and stumbled towards
Darren's car which was parked in a
different location from what I
remembered I was glad to be alive
the mysticum stopped completely Celeste
was downright crying oh we're in a car
now what she pushed me into the back
seat that's when I noticed I was wearing
different clothes from when I lost
consciousness Michael was there huddled
up and face buried in his knees some
clothes stained with blood were beside
him they were mine
Darren immediately stepped on a table
but nothing happened he sworn did again
I noticed that Celeste was armed with
the shotgun from the cabin I asked what
was going on the thing joined us he
looked like you when we go to the house
and found a car we're halfway down the
road then Michael started
deeming he glaze he had a glazed look
over his eyes if they were steadier
clothes and jumped out of the car
michael--ah the shotgun he was firing
out the window we saw those things run
all the way back to the house oh the
thing at frigging speed of light it was
in my skin yeah I looked down to myself
I wondered if I had been possessed or if
worse the thing had cut off my skin and
worried as a coat how do they know that
you're the real one then I asked Michael
if he was alright the thing talked to me
I asked about what he didn't respond I
realized he was signed oh that's the car
the car jolted into motion
Darren fist-pumped as the car started
yeah I turned back toward the cabin and
saw the albino thing standing on the
roof of the house watching this I
shuddered and turned back Celeste
screamed whoa the thing was in front of
the car on the windshield
that doesn't look giant but it's ugly
can open its mouth and my tongue face my
tongue face slithered out Celeste fired
well that was smart the glass was
shattered and it was thrown backwards
Darren shrieked and I saw blood coming
from his face something pierced my face
and I realised it was the glass the car
skidded to a stop
great job Celeste the car doors opened
without any discernible reason and I
fell out a lot of things seemed to be
happening without any discernible reason
the thing lay directly across from me
eyes closed as if it was sleeping I
wished I could close my eyes its mouth
hung open and I saw myself again
emerging I didn't move or say anything
because I couldn't my face looked at me
and started to talk I love you I love
you I love you I want to be with you it
repeated over and over again it was
coming close to me I wondered if it was
going to bite me to death the things I
shot opened and I realized it was gonna
kiss me oh you devil I managed to regain
some control and instinctively twisted
back from
it I guess that was what sir oh there
was a sound like an explosion and blood
spouted from the thing Celeste was
standing over and like a badass her face
and body were bleeding and she had a
spaced out psychopathic looked in her
eyes like a badass
Jesus fired the shotgun my face looked
directly at me like a badass I am you I
am you she fired again and I saw my own
face begin rotting to nothing more than
a skeleton in front of me the things had
flowered open that's the best word I can
find to describe it
its head kind of split and split again
peeling away I saw faces lots of them
all inside its head I think I saw
Celeste in Mike man oh don't do that
okay forgive all that ooh in the center
with a brain should be there was a
single red cat like I that was rotating
in its socket it was producing the
mechanical droning sound oh one last
shot and it withered away becoming
smaller and run okay you can shut up now
game seriously shut up Thank You Celeste
drop the shotgun I started twitching in
spasming as my body returned to me
eventually I stood up we got into the
car silently Darren was bleeding too but
no one said anything we drove back into
the city in silence it's fun because in
this microphone I can actually get close
into a sexier voice we explained away
the damaged car is being attacked by
some crazy thieves we had ourselves
patched up Michael was still in shock
like state I hear he was like that for a
while when I asked him what he thought
of the incident he denied it ever
happened with compelling conviction his
eyes looked dead and he had lost weight
I don't know if he forced himself not to
remember it or if he genuinely knows
nothing of it I know what I saw and I
can't remember the exact place no but I
can't remember it has been two months
now we still refrain from talking about
it
if you were expecting some huge twist or
something you'd be disappointed oh I
guess that wasn't good enough what was
happening the totally bonkers insane
story I still don't know what we met out
there I don't know want to know actually
I still have nightmares about my own
face shouting I am you one thing I do
know though I am never going camping
ever again I think I'm feeling you on
that one and it's not good and but it's
an end okay we have officially reached
every end of this game I think if not
I'm not going back to find it either way
that was pretty good I mean it was very
word heavy in story heavy but I actually
had fun with it a few things didn't make
sense there in terms of the story after
a while but I mean yeah whatever it
wasn't that bad it wasn't bad at all it
had some very creepy moments in it it
just I wish they'd had done more with it
it seems like they kind of rushed
through the last part I didn't have any
actual control after I went outside the
cabin it was just me reading I couldn't
do anything and why would my friends
trust me after they just saw me not
being real and I'm in different freakin
clothes so some things don't make sense
it needed some work but it wasn't awful
hope you guys had a fun time watching it
anyway or listening to my sotry voice
because that's what this whole game was
basically just an exercise for me to
read for you guys so if you like that
sort of thing you're welcome and if you
didn't well I'm sorry anyway so I'm
still at LA I'm still gonna be in LA for
a long time I'm still gonna be very very
busy I'm gonna be trying my best to get
these game play out to you but luckily
as we get in later into the week the
videos that I've been working on while I
am here will be starting to release so
hopefully you guys will see something
really cool in the upcoming few days
also I will try to get as many game
things as I can and not get kicked in
the balls again that wasn't very fun so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye